hi my name is Chris Ghani and I'm an
agile coach today I will talk about
invest and this is a mnemonic that helps
us remember a good starting point for
the definition of ready the definition
of ready is a documented team agreement
it defines the conditions that must be
met for a product backlog item to be
considered ready to work on by the team
it's not a formal contract or approval
gate but rather a set of guidelines that
will help your team make a good
trade-off between minimizing risks and
getting started creating and following
the definition of ready diligently can
easily double the speed in an agile team
that's because the team can stay focused
on shipping working software not chasing
down requirements for a real-world
example think of the nice and plus or
everything in its place concept used by
chefs and cooking shows before they
begin preparing the recipe they
carefully organize and measure the
various ingredients so they're
immediately at hand while cooking a
little careful preparation goes a long
way so what's invest well I like to add
a you in front for you this but you
don't have to use stands for use your
experience which includes everything
from research wireframes mocks written
content and even visual design now
matura scrum teams with dedicated
designers can research design code test
and ship within a single two-week sprint
if you can't consider making user
experience it prerequisite for
development work beginning I means
independent the backlog item should be
self-contained
in a way that there is no in Sprint
dependency on another backlog item n
means negotiable until the Sprint
formally starts the development team and
product owner can negotiate on the
nature and scope
of the item once the Sprint starts the
product owner should not materially
change the acceptance criteria V means
valuable a backlog item must deliver
value to the stakeholders if you can't
clearly articulate the value for the
work you shouldn't do it
e means estimable the team must be able
to estimate the size of the backlog item
ideally using story points otherwise you
won't be able to effectively manage your
flow of work S means small ideally the
backlog item should not take the team
more than half a sprint to complete t
means testable the backlog item should
include enough information to make test
development possible for instance the
coffee should be between 120 and 130
degrees Fahrenheit is a clear acceptance
criteria then the coffee should be hot
well now you know what invest is go
create a definition of ready with your
team